let's go to Jorge from South Florida
welcome to the show
hey David hi can you hear me I can hear
you how's it going nice meeting you
thank you long time fan
since 2020 actually I've been a fan I
appreciate it I got a question really
like my my family's a little bit
promised I have some issues
talking to him about um bias
commentary so one of the things that I'm
just curious to know
but the whole thing with Paul Pelosi
happening you know
um
the poppy going into his house and
breaking in if it would have been the
other way around if it would have been
prompt in his house and someone brings
him into his house yeah and attacks
Mania Trump I'm wondering of the right
media would have you know attacked and
commented on that segment well you know
the answer to that I know you know the
answer
this is the culture that is encouraged
by democrats who want to defund the
police and let crime run rampant and
open the borders and
that's it's of course what they would
have done
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly and they
would have convinced a lot of people
with it by the way I mean listen they've
convinced a lot of people that this
entire thing was like a false flag
inside job with a gay lover
uh even though there's no evidence of
that and if it were someone breaking
into Trump's house and you know hitting
Melania with a hammer uh they'd be
calling for Congressional hearings it
would be 24 7 on Fox News I can't even
imagine what they would be doing
that's my thought too yeah I just wanted
to put it out there because I'm like you
know like I want to show people and my
friends and family like do you see the
buyers out there like can you really
understand that yeah if it was the other
way around it would just be constant 24
hour like what's going on the world 100
you know so
and I guess that's where I'm frustrated
and um I get those pain points like I do
not see reality but so you said your
family is kind of trumpy what kind of
stuff are they saying
exactly that exactly that that you know
like they literally ate it up you know
Elon Musk published it and they said Hey
look it's you know it's it's already
closed out it's you know it was his
lover and I said well wait that doesn't
make any sense like that is your family
Cuban
um yes they are Cuban so you hit on the
nail with that but actually I was
talking to my in-laws who are kind of a
mix they're from other parts they're
from you know
top America specifically not Argentina I
hope yes oh no oh my god oh that's
horrifying that's horrible I don't want
to say I didn't want to take it I know
you're Argentina
well listen uh you're bumming me out but
it sounds like you're fighting the good
fight and doing what you can to push
back
I'm trying yeah thank you all right
thank you for the call very much
appreciate that there is Jorge from
South Florida